oh you like it out plain like this like
me that [ __ ] was kind of too clean
you know hey yo what's up GQ [ __ ] boy yo
got it like a cup of Cubans your nose
then you got a white cube around there's
more like a smaller all these probably
like 40 or 45 thousand smalls this rose
gold is white though our needs together
sick jurors like clothes so you gotta
wear these to the guilt I wouldn't never
really were on fatty self my favorite is
it's a mixture between rose and white
I just think white giri to me and look
the riches is clean and rich and then
their rows go to me as when you want
flavor like how much strawberry damage
you know that I think my favorite
treatment is the one I got on right now
so like 90,000 so I worked I were this
bad self this one prong sitting yeah I
mean what the damage that counts turn
off to change this to Tony smash this
one so mister little brother but it's
the same you know it's just pave this to
the prom said but to vacate them then
one big been hitting it on the lot
[Music]
a lot of different damage hangs right
hill my favorite is its deeds you know
me got a care in ahead
you also got a carrot in her on the
damage chains you got the rod nation
which mean a lot to me and of course you
got to see mg CMG is the label seem geez
how we got here represent you struggle
you know I'm saying it's a forget chain
brought like 4445 man it's another one
145 150 and they just begin chain that
these like father change candy trendy
like what's going on now I mean but the
more real moneys and they've cared and a
half and they carry chain I leaves like
three hundred three hundred fifty
thousand for a carrot and a half damage
shame it's a look I'll tell you story
about bracelets one time I was in LA and
I owned I bought seven damn in bracelets
you know 70 points eighty points and I
like my jury defeat title one of my
homeboy would telling me like he was too
tight and on top oh I'm like now I like
you to fit time I went to the oh I think
it was the ASCAP Awards saying night I
cut my dad's cap award I'm missing three
bracelets I just bought in the same
night it's crazy loss you know me so
I've been you know I've been light on
the bracelet is Cindy and I just got
these these news all these baguettes
they go with the baguette change I leave
he's like I say probably 35 44 inch
piece I called he just Super Bowl rings
I got a made specifically for Super Bowl
of course it's ACMG on the top my lady
was seeing gee I feel like we already
worn a Super Bowl so I wasn't going for
neither team I was going for my team
each one on represent an artist and I
work with you just represent black
gangsta say here we count this represent
block boy JV BG represent pregame in
funny Bay Hill
she wanted to represent different
artists that we work with a LifeFlight
we lose was part of a career it's our
fault and championship actually haven't
bumped into them in a minute so I'll
know if I want to say this on Hill but I
want to just give him the reins when I
see him I get to me because I got to
keep one two cuz you know I had to
represent a champion this is a little
play ring you know I mean I had a
bracelet that was too long and they
could it and they took the extra stones
and just made a ring out of it and I put
it on I said it mare to the game I think
watches hold a value way more than
entity chains and I spent me as a means
of dollars on jury before and she didn't
really you know be what they say it was
so but I'm addicted to the game so I
just try to spend most of my money on
all watches it's the big boy you know me
240,000 2250 I think it went up you know
I mean that's been 250 I think it went
up a couple thousand know a lot of
people got Richard minister thing at the
big wolf on tomorrow's go Casey some of
them look the same but they're not the
same maybe stainless steel in the middle
because all roads go to hold cases big
it's another playing with your bills
like I'll hunt down I'm running into the
Richard Mille brand because I think the
watches keep going up and this one's
just a fun some of the jury right here I
do it because when I'm on stage you know
I'm saying the damage pop so there's the
cheaper version like 170 my favor
watching newest watches is the Kelly
Kelly called the Chandeleur shut up
Kelly he got the all did we get a P so
this all will get 300,000
you saved a lot of watches he's crazy
ever since you got the tick I've been
head this one about this watch maybe for
65 70 thousand when I bought it
now I heard his worth like $100,000 Tate
this is it's kind of like Oh pre-given
and when I meet the right girl out here
on the road I'm gonna give you two so I
already have it on babe
in case I meet some nice fish that's
wrong it isn't rolling at me for like 27
20,000
it gotta be for the right young lady you
know I mean would be right you know I
mean I would say bad watches you know me
save money the right watch is like real
estate somebody watches it's worth more
than what I paid for but at the same
time you know just make sure you pay per
rifle you get to [ __ ] around with a
lot of this jury's cool make sure your
paper right because you can you can lose
a lot of money me [ __ ] - like I told
idea earlier in my career I'm saying
it's addictive you percent so no one
should jump into gay you might be stuck
it again
[Music]